todos los colegios de Francia respetaron
Un minuto de silencio en homenaje añes
la sal profesora de español que fue
asesinada el día de ayer mientras
dictaba clase allí en el establecimiento
donde ella enseñaba varios estudiantes y
padres de familia estuvieron allí en la
ceremonia momento doloroso pero
importante el de rendir homenaje a una
mujer que por más de 25 años dedicó su
vida a la enseñanza también en la tarde
hubo una rueda de prensa por parte del
fiscal a cargo de la investigación que
dio a conocer un poco más de detalles
acerca de las motivaciones del joven de
16 años que asesinó a su profesora de
español Este joven que dice escuchar una
voz en su cabeza que lo incita a hacer
el mal que habría tenido además una
disputa con uno compañero la noche
anterior y que buscaba de alguna manera
poder castigar a este compañero con el
que tuvo este diferendo un joven
brillante muy buen estudiante excepto en
español por eso el fiscal señalaba que
habría una cierta animosidad de El joven
hacia su profesora de español un joven
que además pues venía siendo tratado por
un médico psiquiatra porque había
intentado quitarse la vida a finales del
año pasado Este joven Se le realizó
también una evaluación psicológica en la
que se descartó toda enfermedad mental y
enfermedad o enfermedad psiquiátrica lo
cual no lo exime de responsabilidad
penal a pesar de la personalidad ansiosa
que sobresale después de esta evaluación
En todo caso la fiscalía abrirá a partir
de mañana una investigación o judicial
por asesinato preme